in the movie Paddington you were playing
a villain yeah which is and I have to
say I mentioned this earlier in the show
one of my all-time favorite movies is to
die for you play kind of a sociopath I
would say in that in that film it's such
a great such a great depiction though of
that character you like to play a kind
of an evil character or a twisted
character I mean when you're at drama
school I always tell you they're the
best roles right so you kind of I I
would have liked to in Paddington have
played the Bears mummy because I have
little kids and they were mortified Oh
playing the villain that must be tough
when you have little kids and you say
I'm in the Paddington the bear me like
yay mommy what part are you and you say
I'm the one that wants to kill
Paddington I used the word stuff the
bear you want to stuff the bit I play a
taxidermist yes so any any bears a
natural enemy is the day exactly did you
did your own stunts in this movie is
that right yeah I did when I first got
there actually they had me go like
literally 60 feet up when we were
rehearsing
they said quick I got off the plane and
they said no no it's all safe you can go
up on these these wires and so they put
you in wires and they gave you 60 feet
into the air yeah they told me it was
safe I mean I'm still here but uh no you
never listen people are always telling
me oh yeah go ahead do that it's safe
and then later when I'm on fire I have a
discussion with them but they but they
took you up you weren't scared or
anything no I was scared yeah I was
really scared but everyone was so kind
of cool about it that I was like okay
and then so I had to pretend to be cool
about it right and then they said turn
around I was up the top and they're like
look turn over on your head and did it
all afterwards they said to me we
couldn't believe you did that
yeah we didn't think that was safe at
all
those pliers are very old we really
don't know what we're doing you'd rather
hear that afterwards I think we have a
picture of you being a suspect that is
yeah that was the first day I actually
was so impressed with myself that I got
my friend to take the photo obvious like
take the photo take the photo now your
kids are young this is a kiss a movie
for kids are they gonna see Paddington
even though you're playing the bad guys
I've seen it they've seen it yeah would
they think they loved the movie now I
mean at first they were mortified but
then the idea of the whole thing I mean
it's it's genuinely funny and sometimes
you come and you have to promote movies
and they're you know they're okay this
is actually really good that's the most
that's the most honest thing I think
I've ever heard someone in your position
say yeah I'm gonna get in trouble you're
saying this one's really good but I've
been here I've been doing this 22 years
people come here you gotta go see
biodome 9 it's really good
you